j'adore ce site là
[Musique]
le jardin est toujours structuré avec
une fontaine centrale qui symbolise la
fontaine de jouvence donc la jeunesse
éternelle
et cette fontaine est entouré par quatre
carrés de verdure qui représentent les
quatre fleuves du paradis autour de ce
paradis l'enfer est représentée par la
nature sauvage et indomptable c'est à
dire la forêt
les jardins de dons paciello avait
plusieurs caractéristiques prédominante
devait ressortir notamment des paillages
avec des minéraux coloré l'idée de
géométrie ou l'utilisation de plantes
simples comme les petits ou comme la
lavande se permettent aussi d'avoir de
la couleur toute l'année et ici on
soigne les plantes tout naturel
c'est un signe de richesse à cette
époque quand vous avez une collection
d'agrumes il faut la montrer
les peaux sont très importants à
l'origine ce sont des barriques qu'on va
couper dont paciello mais ses orangers à
l'intérieur ce qui lui permet de faire
des mélanges de terre et surtout ça lui
permet de faire rouler ses orangers et
donc de les rentrer ou de les sortir
selon les températures qui le souhaitent
il faut les arroser surtout bien les
arroser
[Musique]
il se place très bien
on a le don paciello de charlie 8 qu'on
essaye de réhabiliter et on à léonard de
vinci qui va arriver un tout petit peu
plus tard qui arrive avec françois 1er
et dont chaque roi à son génie italien
[Musique]